es una ceremonia perfectamente
organizada delante de miles de
seguidores reunidos en un estadio de
addis abeba la alcaldesa de la capital
pasa revista a los nuevos reclutas
militares en unos días estos hombres
irán al frente para intentar frenar el
avance de los rebeldes hacia la ciudad
ya
organicémonos todos estemos todos
preparados ciudadanos policías y fuerzas
armadas trabajan día y noche olvidemos
al cansancio no tenemos derecho a estar
cansados en este momento crítico
[Música]
es una ciudad en pie de guerra
el avance relámpago de los rebeldes tomó
por sorpresa al gobierno tras haber
controlado el tigre el mes de julio
acaban de hacerse con dos ciudades
estratégicas en la región de amhara el
miércoles se encontraban a 300
kilómetros de la capital donde se les
unieron combatientes del ejército de
liberación oromo otra facción rebelde
ahora el gobierno llama a sus
partidarios a frenar el avance de los
que califican como terroristas y etiopía
no se derrumbará etiopía prosperará
etiopía existirá para siempre
el parlamento ha declarado el estado de
emergencia en todo el país desde hace un
año el conflicto entre el gobierno y los
rebeldes ha dado un giro espectacular
con la retirada forzada del ejército
etíope
a raíz de este conflicto la suerte de
los civiles de la región preocupa mucho
a la comunidad internacional según la
onu más de 400.000 personas están al
borde de la hambruna